it's a wonderful
Whitehall until he just announced it cuz
your and my phone is Jack puppy puppy I
love that emergency lipstick and if you
guys don't know this is where babies
come from Jack and I met on a magical
night out when I ate myself more than
I've ever had
it was probably the best moment of my
life have you sorted out all your visas
because I know was it when you were
auditioning for the first episod yeah
was it you have to come here to do it
it's just like what this is just
humiliate Jennifer day I was auditioning
for the first x-men my passport was
expiring under six months which
apparently are not supposed to travel
bah-bah-bah so they were like whatever
you do don't tell them that you're here
for work cuz I'll ask for a work visa
say you're here for pleasure and I'm
like oh my good god customs officer and
so I'm working myself up so much through
the line I'm like okay I just have to
have a backstory to believe it and and
so it gets there and he was like
business or pleasure and I was like
pleasure what are you doing for pleasure
my brothers getting married where is he
getting married Wimbledon is the
American yes do you have an invitation
no are you telling the truth no you
little jail
my employer I felt tiny was it wasn't
the night you won your Oscar the night I
won my I don't want to talk about that
night I had a whole meltdown birth
control confusion so I was like hormonal
fell on my face I forgot to thank the
director so I was just like what does it
all mean nothing burst into her bathroom
with a BB gun well she was trying to pee
in the middle to let the rest of it go
out like that's a whole really hard like
there's a lot going on and then he burst
in and started pelting me and it wasn't
fair because we were all shooting each
other with guns but you all were all in
clothes we were all naked we were
telling this and we were saying like she
there we we're and she's like huddled on
the floor in her bathroom naked and I'm
we're done loading on her
get an Abercrombie model yeah hey no
don't make your whose to be a story so
my pictures never came out it did like
the whole campaign the pictures never
came out and I didn't know why am i a
gent wrote and asked why and they
literally only responded with the photos
they like their home like idea was like
we want real people so they you know
they like God he did I don't know we
were like on a beach and then they threw
us a football and they're like play
football and all the other models were
like playing football like in a pretty
way you know like and that me I was all
of the photos I've got a red face
covered in sweat my nostrils are flared
like at one point a girly girl just get
her away from me you buy the BB gun
but you've also done is it did you do a
punching game this is her game she did
this game what
I just wanted to protect my drink
Chito is this game i even TI brought it
you did bring we used to do it in The
Hunger Games in like a normal way
because you're bored you know you spend
minimum 12 hours on set so it's like you
know you see the circle you get punched
and on Hunger Games that's normal I
brought it to these psychos and now it's
it's truly truly dangerous
did you look the first time ever in my
career I never assume anyone knows who I
am and I saw Harrison Ford and like JJ
Abrams and I was like I was like yeah
this is fine we're all co-workers like I
can just go so I was like be right back
guys I'm gonna go say hi to the Star
Wars dudes and I approached their table
and was like and they all the whole
table is just like I realized while I
was dancing I was like they have no idea
who I am
and so I just turned around and walked
back met the trumpet all things Jennifer
I haven't no I was at the dog sir and I
heard he was attending so I had my full
security like I was like fine Donald
Trump because I was just I was adamant
on finding him and then making a video
of me going
hey trunk [__] you what a vagina
it's a chat show not a whispering she's
going okay so I had next phone oh there
he is um and they we were at a group
message with Fassbender and McAvoy and
Josh Helman another actor in the movie
and I was like wrote this like really
serious and emotional texture was like
guys there's a super embarrassing and
like I knew how to like kind of write
like Nick like instead of cause like
ause cos Cole's yeah and I was like I
know this sounds silly this is really
embarrassing but have you guys have
heard like god this is so embarrassing
lactated from your nipples sounds really
serious though honestly like you should
go to a doctor you might have a hormone
problem I don't see what this has to do
with anything
where you going up for this New York
China and I think that's it yeah I'm not
doing you're not doing China no no no I
lied and told him I'm on a movie